[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute gehts komplett
marokkanisch zu hier wir machen das
dinner oder was die ja ich weiß nicht
ganz genau wie man es ausspricht aber
ich weiss niemand so macht und das ist
das wichtige
ich habe das erste mal ende 2016 das
werde ich nie vergessen auf einer
hochzeit probiert da war ich mit der
mama oh mein gott das war sooo lecker
ist so lecker und haben sei es jetzt
kein marokkaner das denken immer viele
wenn ich marokkanische rezepte mache
haben sie kommt aus palästina aber ich
war immer auf dieser mauer kann ja nach
nicht zu denken also wir lieben
marokkaner marokkanische küche sowie so
und ja deswegen machen wir das heute und
zwar im mini format das sind ein
hähnchen was denn die kann man sich
super einfrieren super positionieren
mega ich starte jetzt hier direkt mit
der pfanne und da gebe ich zuallererst
öl rein und dann mit zwiebeln auch schon
dazu ich habe mir ein bisschen was
vorbereitet aber ihr findet die ganz
genauen mengenangaben immer in der video
beschreibung einfach unter dem titel
sind fein anklicken und dann habt ihr
sie da komplett also zwiebeln rein was
ich auch schon mit rein gäbe ist
koriander und petersilie sollte ja was
berührt ist ja habe ich wahrscheinlich
vergessen weil ich war heute der erste
fastentag und ich bin gleich zu mir
passt alle sind so also man nimmt ich
nehme so viel kilo teig und da ist dann
ein hähnchen schicht eine nuss schicht
eine mit dem was wir jetzt machen eben
mit casino koriander und es ist vor
allem bisschen süß und dennoch herzhaft
es ist eine so lecker das ist das kleine
daran ist es so lecker so zwiebeln sind
drin wie gesagt petersilie und koriander
dann kommen auch noch gewürze dazu aber
die zeige ich euch das in aller ruhe
[Musik]
so darf ich auch schon frischen ingwer
mit dazu gegeben ihr könntet auch
gemeinden irgendwann dem je nachdem was
ihr da habt und jetzt kommen noch meine
trockenen gewürze dazu einmal kurkuma
einfach mit rein so zink zimt spielt
eine rolle hier also ich bin jetzt ich
so der tipp wenn aber bei stella mega
einmal rein salz und pfeffer und safran
safran ist auch typisch dafür und ich
mache das so mensch kriegs den pfeffer
ich mache das dann safran so dass ich
den mal der hat ja so relativ lange
stengel war ich mir einfach so ein
bisschen verein in der hand dann werden
sie kürzer nehme ich das mal mit dazu so
jetzt kommt das hähnchen mit dazu und
wird noch von beiden seiten schön
angebraten aber nicht lange denn das
wird gleich im wasser gar gekocht
[Musik]
so jetzt machen wir die nutzschicht und
die ist meine persönliche lieblings
schicht das ist eben der teil der auch
ein bisschen süß sein wird aber nicht zu
sie ist dürft euch das jetzt nicht zu
süß vorstellen ich habe jetzt hier
puderzucker die müsse habe ich vorab
angeröstet dass mandeln die ich benutze
er könnte auch cashewkerne nehmen oder
ab in den kleinen ganz sehen möchtet und
die habe ich jetzt in blender auch noch
ein bisschen feiner gemacht nicht
zufallen die dürfen ruhig um stücke
seien aber es ist auch alles
geschmackssache
so einmal die nüsse zum puderzucker was
ist auch ganz wichtig ist ganz typisch
auch orangenblüten wasser davon gebe ich
jetzt auch noch zwei esslöffel dazu und
dann wird das schön verrührt
[Musik]
zu den muslimischen gesetz fertig und
jetzt widme ich mich dem hähnchen das
ist jetzt auch gab es auch bei mir
ungefähr 20 minuten gedauert es kommt
immer darauf an wie dick ist bei euch
ist also wie dick die fleischstücke sind
deckel weg zu kommen die hähnchen stück
heraus eher dürftig dass sich wundern
warum ich hier so kleine stückchen reden
wir hatten uns ursprünglich für ein
anderes rezept entschieden und ich hatte
meine hähnchenbrust schon in kleinere
stücke geschnitten ihr könnt natürlich
auch ganz raum geben so ihr leben als
nächstes machen folgendes das was jetzt
noch übrig ist im topf diese flüssigkeit
mit den ganzen aromen das nicht
wegschütten das ist jetzt ganz wichtig
da geben wir jetzt ein rein und hoeneß
nach und nach unter und lassen das noch
mal 10 minuten köcheln damit die
flüssigkeit verdampft und wie so eine
richtig schöne er wie so eine art passte
haben und das hähnchen was hier raus
genommen habe clusters ausdampfen das
verbrennt ihr euch und dann einfach
auseinander rufen
[Musik]
wenn die flüssigkeit verdampft dann
sieht das ganze so aus also es ist schon
sehr feld und halt sehr lecker weil die
ganzen verkürze damit drin sind besser
als wenn ihr das was er wegschütten wird
denn wenn die ganzen leckeren aromen mir
auch weg bzw ein teil davon so und jetzt
habe ich hier viele blätter philo teig
das ist der gleiche den hier auch für
baklava benutzer und ich habe hier auch
schon drei vorbereitet ich zeige euch
ist wie ich den vierten vorbereite immer
schön unter dem tuch liegen lassen die
viele blätter die trocknen sehr schnell
aus ich habe zum einen tortenring habe
jetzt hier den monitoren bringen auf
ungefähr 11 cm ein geschäft doch zehn
oder zwölf nehmen ihr können auf 5 sind
also es ist vollkommen egal ich mag es
jetzt halt so und in einer anderen
variante im video von vor zwei jahren
habe ich ja ich glaube ich 30 cm groß
gemacht aber heute wollen wir die mini
variante so ich lege jetzt den vorteig
hier rein und dann habe ich ein bisschen
butter in der mikrowelle geschmolzen
weil der pilot so dünn ist bestreichen
dann immer mit ein bisschen butter in
dem insgesamt zwei oder drei klagen ich
habe gerade mit zwei versucht das war
ein bisschen dünn und am besten drei
klagen
[Musik]
so und jetzt nacheinander schichten ich
nehm zuerst die nuss mischung dann gebe
ich die eier masse dazu und zum schluss
hähnchen und danach verschließen wir das
ganz einfach auch immer ein bisschen
butter drauf geben schön andrücken und
dann könnte es auch schon auf ein
backblech geben das habe ich hier mit
backpapier ausgelegte den backofen habe
ich vorgeheizt auf 180 grad ober
unterhitze und dann müsst einfach gucken
innen ist ja schon alles klar
das heißt es müssen nur so viele blätter
schön braun werden das dauert so
ungefähr 20 bis 25 minuten und dann
können wir auch schon servieren und ich
gebe obendrüber ganz traditionell
puderzucker und sind so und jetzt habt
ihr nur noch eins zu tun das ganze
einmal nachmachen und dann schreibt in
euer feedback hier unten in die
kommentare
habt ihr fragen habt ihr wünsche liegt
irgendwo auf dem herz und immer schön in
die kommentare
wir können miteinander schreiben und ich
freue mich jetzt einfach nur aufs ist
mit dir ja also heute sagt der erste tag
ist man das video online geht aber doch
wir haben schon so langsam echt hunger
und das ist es wird auch langsam dunkel
deswegen müssen wir uns jetzt mal
beeilen also euch noch wunderschönen tag
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten videos
eure ki
[Musik]